Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so we have to
talk about an Aquaman plot teaser and I've got
a Green Lantern story that will blow your
mind the really cool thing is that as I'm
uploading this video.
January 29th it's actually Aquaman's birthday
in the comics not Jason Momoa the character
Aquaman's birthday.
There is a new round of the injustice 2 giveaway
I'm giving away a copy of the game.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave it Aquaman related comment on this
video be sure to click that bell to enable
alerts so that you don't miss anything.
So whole bunch Aquaman stuff is happening
this year they teased that they just got together
with James Wan to start reading the script
you have ocean master Mera and Aquaman himself.
So they're slowly ramping up to actually start
rolling footage they just finished Justice
league there will be a lot of Aquaman in that
Mera is also going to be featured during Justice
league she'll have a brief introduction in
that movie, Jason Momoa has been doing all
kinds of interviews for other projects he's
working on hyping it up.
He let out that he's been keeping Aquaman
secret the fact that he was going to be Aquaman
for five years last time where you're allowed
to say or Aquaman but you will all.
What are you wearing Aqua were Aquaman of
Aquaman file will never guess to be Aquaman
you don't look like the old cartoon of Aquaman
for sure, but hello, did you have to keep
it quiet is it for five years that long about
long why why because that is one of few secret
people did you tell a confidentially now and
until all my friend is is that I don't know
and fingering but I I'm really about, so this
is where we get to Green Lantern DCEU because
if you backdate that he found out that he
was going to be Aquaman before the original
Green Lantern movie came out you can imagine
that was actually supposed to set up the DCEU
the original DCEU.
So all address that at the end of this video
because that original Green Lantern universe
would've been so different than the one today
but the plot teaser stuff goes into Geoff
John's who is now like Mr. DC movies and Aquaman
stuff that he was writing a couple years ago
and the poster that they dropped last year
when they tease Aquaman was coming to the
movies so the big thing is is they release
this poster previously called unite the seven
when they reveal what Aquaman was going to
look like during Justice league at least without
his full armor on since then we got pictures
of what he looks like with his Atlantean armor.
So it some point in the movie he'll get that.
But we don't know exactly where he is when
we pick up with them when Bruce's meeting
with him here in this trailer.
It does not sound like he's King of Atlantis
in the way they explain his relationship to
Mera in the movie they're not together unmarried
so this is a very free King of Atlantis Aquaman.
So part of the movie is Jason the Moa explains
it is explaining where Aquaman's been where
he's at right now and where is headed in the
future the cool thing is that the teaser poster
gives us an idea for what the plot of the
movie is going to be uniting the seven kingdoms
of the nation of Atlantis.
If you haven't read the comics Aquaman is
the king of Atlantis this big undersea city
it's this ancient culture, but the thing is
is that there's the city of Atlantis and there
is the United Nations of Atlantis and there
are seven kingdoms below the ocean.
We only know about three of them as of the
new 52 there was this big storyline.
The Geoff John's was teasing called rise of
the seven seas that he was going to be doing
before they did rebirth now he's tease that
he's writing a Dr. Manhattan, comic, so they
neither postponed that rise of the seven seas
or the doing something else or the not doing
anymore but it was going to be a big Justice
league story about the return of these missing
Atlantean kingdoms.
So that might be part of what happens during
the Aquaman movie a call the movie something
of a swashbuckling adventure.
So imagine it moving like one of the Pirates
movies from that franchise only using DC characters
with a much stronger story with some deeper
mythology don't have to read the comics but
I think next to the flash movie.
It's gonna be one of the most fun DC comics
movies that Aquaman is the most hard core
member next to Batman Justice league, so you
have to imagine is gonna dominate the two
half hours of that movie, and I imagine that
he and Mera will be together by the end of
that like they know each other in Justice
league, but she doesn't really like and that
much to get to know each other than they do
the Lewis and Clark things through the Aquaman
movie the rise of the seven kingdoms storyline
is pretty cool.
It involves the return of the original King
of Atlantis the one who actually created Atlantis,
but it involves this really big twist with
Aquaman's Backstory that recontextualize is
everything he knows about his people in his
origins.
So originally, he thinks he's the son of Atlan,
The first King of the United seven nations
of Atlantis.
So he has this open borders policy there are
isolationist within his government led by
his brother who stage a coup try to kill him
kill his wife he escapes.
So at land using special magic forms the special
Trident that he then uses to sink Atlantis
in an act of revenge against his brother in
the people that killed his family Aquaman
learns to his horror that he's actually the
son of the king's brother Oren who effectively
makes him one of the villains of this other
king story in present day Atlan comes back
from the dead.
They call in the dead king could he's been
dead this whole time.
So he rises up and seeks to finish his revenge
against Atlantis, but they explain when he
sunk all seven kingdoms of Atlantis that only
three survived including the city of Atlantis
the trench which is the group of people that
live inside the Marianas trench is basically
a bunch of monsters and then several the other
four are missing they tease that they're coming
back during the rise of the seven seas Justice
league title, but because that was all happening
a couple years ago that might be part of what
the Aquaman script is part of the big mythology
that there teasing out because Geoff John's
is bringing back all this old continuity from
before the new 52.
A lot of people felt like these four missing
kingdoms were things that were dealt with
during Peter David's run on Aquaman a long
time ago, which would be tritone us a sidedness
venture area and Thea and in the Ogg see don't
totally need to understand what those of the
lost nations are the just the idea of Aquaman
healing his peoples, not just the people in
the city of Atlantis.
So he's uniting the undersea world in the
way that Superman will eventually unite the
surface lands, or at least try to as like
a crazy idea like even though Superman is
the most amazing superhero ever there's still
a lot of people fighting there still villains
everywhere.
So it's the same deal with Aquaman.
If you want to learn a little bit more about
the character the rebirth title is actually
really good to the first issue gives you a
really good idea of the scope of the things
that he deals with.
You have to imagine that more of the earth
is covered with water then isn't so.
The amount of people that he has to deal with
and his kingdom basically everything underwater
is much greater than what happens above water.
So what they might also do is incorporate
some of the throne of Atalanta storyline,
which is basically him reclaiming the throne
of the city of Atlantis from ocean master.
So, I know a lot of people are thinking of
wonder woman is more of the Thor of the Justice
league, but Aquaman story seems a little bit
more like what's been happening in the Thor
movies with Loki versus Thor battle for the
throne, even though technically Thor doesn't
want it but Aquaman doesn't want the throne
either.
So if you haven't already.
I would recommend that you check out the throne
of Atalantis's movie is just like the other
more recent DC comics movies that come out,
they just released Justice league dark.
I know a lot of you asked me to do a story
for but it doesn't really have anything to
do with what's going on in the movies right
now, even though they're actually developing
a live action Justice league dark but can
we just imagine what the DC comics universe
would have looked like originally had Green
Lantern been a success.
You can imagine thematically how the storyline
of man of steel dealt with the idea of the
world.
Reacting to an alien the original story of
Green Lantern became this big assault on coast
city.
So imagine parallax attacks coast city, there's
this big crazy alien attack the earth learns
about the Green Lantern Corps that then becomes
the entry point not Superman in the way they
wrote it to his really crazy.
They actually said that as the ring is coming
to Hal Jordan like searching for a replacement.
It belies by Clark Kent in Metropolis.
Meaning that Superman already existed on that.
So that was in the Greg Berlanti script not
in the rewritten script that actually end
up making it to screen, so a lot of people
always wonder what the original Green Lantern
look like it was just way weirder in a good
way it had a lot more emerald Don stuff and
by the end of the movie he would have like
the silver temples like he does in the comics
there was just a lot more comic book he stuff
in it they did up turning it into more of
a paint by numbers safe movie like they did
want to take any chances with it and that's
part of what led to its demise along with
really bad CG, but that's another story.
They basically use Superman is the jumping
off point for the DC universe alien comes
to earth everyone freaks out and we get Batman
view Superman as the reaction to that moving
it to Justice league and everything else,
but it would've been cool if we had Green
Lantern to start with, so that's why a lot
of people are like okay we have the Green
Lantern Corps movie that they just announced.
It doesn't necessarily have to link up with
the Justice league movies yet but it sounds
like they're going to be teasing Hal Jordan
during Justice league somewhere whether or
not we actually see him in a costume or see
him on screen but congratulations to the new
injustice giveaway winner KD flash please
private message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details.
There was a new round that started in this
video just announce the winner when I post
new flash tomorrow while you guys wait for
that to post you can click here to learn all
about the Green Lantern Corps movie they just
announced and you can click here to learn
all about the Super Bowl trailers coming next
week, thank you so much watching everybody
thought five I'll see you guys next video!